damit kommen wir zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt wenn auch die
namentliche Abstimmung weiterhin in der
westlobby hier noch läuft noch eine gute
Viertelstunde geht es hier dann trotzdem
im Plenum schon mal weiter und da geht
es um das sogenannte Familien ist
splitting die AFD hatte schon in ihrem
Wahlkampf ein solches Familiensplitting
gefordert und damit für sich geworben es
geht darum Familien z.B durch die
Kinderfreibeträge mehr steuerlich zu
entlasten und z.B Familien ab dem
dritten Kind bis zu einem
Jahreseinkommen von 100.000 € von der
Einkommensteuer zu befreien
Sache und dazu gibt es jetzt von der
afd-fraktion hier auch zwei Anträge die
hier
jetzt
diskutiert werden unter anderem fordert
die afd-fraktion da die Bundesregierung
auch auf ein Gesetzentwurf vorzulegen
mit dem auf bestimmte Produkte
nicht mehr mit 19% besteuert werden
sondern nur noch mit 7% nämlich
Kinderartikel und Dienstleistungen mit
kindesbezug das wird hier gleich noch
mal der familienpolitische Sprecher der
afd-fraktion auch erläutern Martin
Reichert ist ja schon als erster Redner
angekündigt aber es dürfte auch
interessant sein was die Fraktion der
Ampel Koalition in dieser Debatte sagen
denn die Ampel Koalition möchte ja dass
Ehegattensplitting weiter
abschaffen zum Teil zumindest von daher
wird das eine interessante Debatte Damen
und Herren diese Regierung versucht wie
schon viele Regierungen vor ihr
erfolglos Kinderarmut zu bekämpfen wobei
der Begriff Kinderarmut in die Irre
führt denn kinderarmut ist familienarmut
und deshalb müssen Familien unterstützt
werden passiert ist in den letzten
Jahrzehnten viel zu wenig ständig
steigen die Zahlen von Kindern die in
Armut leben Eltern sein erhöht das
Risiko arm zu sein und Eltern sind
unfreiwillig Arm meine Damen und Herren
auch deshalb sind die Geburtenraten
historisch niedrig deshalb werden
Kinderwünsche nicht erfüllt statt das
Armutsrisiko durch Kinder zu senken
handelt die Politik konträr sie kassiert
bei Eltern ab seit einem halben
Jahrhundert leistet sich Deutschland
eine der weltweit niedrigsten
Geburtenraten die Folgen der
demografischen Katastrophe werden immer
offensichtlicher
Sozialsysteme kollabieren
Fachkräftemangel lähmt Industrie und
Handwerk der Auftrag einer jeden
Bundesregierung ist es für den Bestand
des staatsvolks und damit für die
Zukunft des Staates Sorge zu tragen
anstatt einer aktivierenden
Familienpolitik setzt unsere Regierung
aber auf Massenmigration über zwei
Millionen Menschen sind in den letzten
sechs Jahren über das Asylsystem
eingewandert 60 Milliarden Euro kostet
uns diese verfehlte Politik der
Bundesregierung nach offiziellen Angaben
Geld meine Damen und Herren Familien
fehlt Geld das in Familien nachhaltig
angelegt wäre und das jetzt endlich
angelegt werden muss
mit unseren beiden Anträgen wollen wir
Familien gerade in der heutigen
Situation von Inflation und steigenden
Energiekosten aber auch langfristig
entlasten mit dem Antrag zum
Familiensplitting wollen wir Familien
stärken die Arbeiten und Steuern zahlen
mit der Senkung der Mehrwertsteuer auf
7% für Artikel des Kinder und
familienbedarfs entlasten wir die
Familien direkt an der Kasse die AFD
will als einzige Fraktion in diesem
Hause einen wirklichen Paradigmenwechsel
wir wollen Familien in den Mittelpunkt
der Politik stellen
mit dem von uns geforderten
Familiensplitting wird Familien endlich
Steuergerechtigkeit zu teilen ein
Familiensplitting bei dem die Anzahl der
Kinder in der Einkommenssteuer gewichtet
wird ein Familiensplitting bei dem
Familien mit ein bis zwei Kindern
spürbar entlastet werden und eine
durchschnittliche Familie mit drei
Kindern keine Steuern mehr bezahlt das
das Kindergeld soll darüber hinaus ohne
günstiger Prüfung weiter gezahlt werden
denn wir brauchen starke Familien die
sich wieder trauen ja zu Kindern und
Familien zu sagen das ist nicht wie das
hier einige Fraktionen im linken Bereich
meinen rückwärtsgewandt sondern zutiefst
modern und ein Bekenntnis zur Zukunft
Deutschlands
unsere vor unsere Forderung die
Mehrwertsteuer für Produkte des Kinder
und familienbedarfs zu senken haben wir
bereits in der letzten Legislatur
gestellt und gerade in Zeiten hoher
Inflation werden besonders Familien mit
mittleren und geringen Einkommen
überproportional belastet denn sie
decken vielfach ihre Grundbedürfnisse im
Wesentlichen mit der Senkung der
Mehrwertsteuer werden alle Familien
direkt entlastet jeder der Kinder hat
kennt die Kosten Windeln Schul- und
Bastelmaterial Bekleidung Schuhe und so
weiter und so weiter alleine bei der
Erstausstattung für Neugeborene und der
Kinderkleidung sparen Familien für das
Neugeborene im ersten Jahr 450 Euro
Kinder meine Damen und Herren sind eben
nicht politisch verfügbar Kinder sind
nicht rechts oder links sie sind eben
einfach Kinder und darum muss in diesem
Hohen Hause eine Koalition aller
Parteien entstehen mit dem Ziel die
Kinderarmut wirksam zu bekämpfen vielen
Dank
und für die SPD für die SPD-Fraktion
spricht nun Michael schrodi SPD-Fraktion
und Mitglied im Finanzausschuss
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren die
afd-fraktion stellt zu Anträge einen
davon hat sie vor eineinhalb Jahren
schon einmal gestellt da wird die
Bundesregierung aufgefordert ein Gesetz
vorzulegen zum Familiensplitting der
Antrag ist nahezu identisch jetzt noch
mal eingebracht es gab damals keinen
Grund dafür zu sein diese Antrag ist
sogar noch mal nochmals ist verschwinden
noch mal schlechter geworden insofern
gibt es keinen Grund dem zuzustimmenden
anders als sie es hier behauptet haben
tut diese Antrag nichts gegen
Kinderarmut das ist auch gar nicht Ihr
Anliegen deshalb leben wir Ihnen den
Antrag auch ab erstens mal was geht
ihnen tatsächlich
wenn wir über Familienförderung über
Förderung von Kinder sprechen dann
denken wir daran beispielsweise dass es
um Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf
geht dass es um gesellschaftliche
Teilhabe von Männern und Frauen geht das
ist um meine sorgenfreies Aufwachsen von
Kindern geht um Chancengleichheit für
unsere Kinder tatsächlich ist das was
sie hier vorlegen ein Paradigmenwechsel
wäre es nämlich eine Rolle rückwärts ins
letzte Jahrtausend der Familienpolitik
und den werden wir sicher nicht
mitmachen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren die AFD denkt
an die alleinverdienerehe
sie denkt an die Frau im Haushalt
und sie denkt vor allem es ist ein
zentraler Punkt in diesem Antrag anders
Geburtendefizit sie haben sogar richtig
zitiert aus ihrem Grundsatzprogramm die
AFD fürchtet
den die Schrumpfung wie sie schreibt
unsere angestammten Bevölkerung und
deshalb sei der Erhalt des eigenen
staatsvolksvorrangige Aufgabe der
Politik heißt also die Frau reduziert
auf die Rolle der Mutter der Hausfrau
der Gebärenden eine Rolle rückwärts das
ist keine Familienpolitik sondern gute
nationalistische bevölkerungsideologie
die sie hier vortragen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
zweitens wenn wir an Familienpolitik
denken dann wollen wir erreichen das
Kinder
kein Armutsrisiko sind
dass Kinder nicht in Armut aufwachsen
müssen wir haben da noch etwas vor uns
das ist uns
bekannt wir wollen das finanziell
schwächere Familien ein gutes Leben für
können das Kinder auch aus
finanziell schwächeren Familien Chancen
haben
der afd-antrag macht genau das Gegenteil
er fördert vor allen Dingen besser
verdiene Familien mit hohem Einkommen
warum ist das so sie wollen diejenigen
diejenigen besonders fördern die drei
oder mehr Kinder haben auch da wird
schon klar es geht nicht darum Familien
zu fördern sondern mehr Geburten zu
fördern
aber es geht auch darum und es haben sie
in ihrem Antrag formuliert um die
Förderung von höchsten Einkommen wie und
warum ist das so sie wollen das Familien
ab dem dritten Kind bis zu einem
Jahreseinkommen von
100.000 Euro
völlig oder nahezu von der
Einkommensteuer freigestellt werden ich
glaube sie wissen gar nicht was das
eigentlich in der Einkommensverteilung
bedeutet bis wohin sie entlassen wollen
das sind bis in die fünf Prozent
höchsten Einkommen die
Spitzenverdiener in diesem Land die sie
vollkommen von der Steuer befreien
wollen und die 20% Familien mit dem
geringsten Einkommen würden davon gar
nicht profitieren weil die unter dem
Grundfreibetrag liegen und deswegen gar
nicht von dieser Maßnahme profitieren
würden das heißt sie entlasten die
Spitzenverdiener
die Familien die es dringend bräuchten
mit den kleinen Einkommen überhaupt
nicht sie machen Umverteilung von unten
nach oben und das werden wir auch nicht
mitmachen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren übrigens
im letzten Antrag zwar 21.04 des letzten
Jahres waren sie zumindest ein bisschen
ehrlicher weil sie da reingeschrieben
haben was das eigentlich kosten würde
bis zu 67
Milliarden Euro jährlich würde dieses
Geschenk für Superreiche bedeuten ohne
dass sie einmal sagen wo sie das
gegenfinanzieren wollen das ist Finanz
wo du aber keine
Finanzpolitik mit Augenmaß und natürlich
auch mit der falschen Richtung deswegen
auch leben wir diesen Antrag ab und der
Antrag hilft nicht er verschärft
Probleme die Antrag setzt Anreize für
Frauen zu Hause zu bleiben er
degradierte Frauen
und Mutter
Fraktion nicht und er liegt vom er er
hilft Familien nicht er schadet
die Ampelkoalition hat sich vorgenommen
und auch schon umgesetzt
für Familien etwas zu tun Kindern zu
helfen in der Infrastruktur mit der
guten Sets auch schon eine große
Koalition jetzt mit dem
kita-qualitätsgesetz werden wir das
Betreuungsangebot verbessern das hilft
auch Familien und Familie und Beruf
zusammenzubringen und hilf
beispielsweise auch Frauen einen eine
Arbeit einzunehmen in ihrem Ohr wenn
Frauen zu Hause bleiben das ist die
Altersarmut der Zukunft denn wenn sie
nicht in die Arbeit geht dann bricht
teilt sie auch nicht in die Rente ein
und das ist die Altersarmut von Frauen
für morgen da wollen sie Frauen hin
haben da wollen wir sie nicht haben das
wollen sie gleichberechtigt in unserer
Gesellschaft in unserer Mitte haben
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren zum
zweiten wir haben den Kinderfreibetrag
erhöht wir haben ja Alleinerziehende
Freiheit jetzt eine gute
Steuergesetz erhöht das Kindergeld
so stark erhöht wie noch nie in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und wir werden auch das ist
vereinbart in dieser Koalition die
Kinder Grundsicherung auf den Weg
bringen die gerade bei helfen wird
Kinder aus der Armut zu bringen Familien
genau anders als sie es wollen
diejenigen die finanziell schwächer sind
die Hilfen brauchen finanziell stärker
zu machen finanziell zu entlasten und
die dies nicht brauchen eben nicht das
heißt wir machen sozialgerechte Politik
für die Familien in diesem Land das wäre
weiterhin tun und ihren Anteil natürlich
ablehnen
und der nächste Redner der Debatte ist
Johannes steiniger für die
Unionsfraktion und auch Johannes
Steininger sitzt im Finanzausschuss
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegen Kollegen
zunächst mal ich weiß gar nicht ob sie
das alle gehört haben also ich finde es
unmöglich wie hier reingepflückt wird
von den Kollegen Kollegen der AFD hier
wird der Kollege schroti als
vaterlandsloser Geselle beleidigt ich
finde es eine Unverschämtheit diejenigen
die unpatriotisch sind in diesem Land
ist ihre Fraktion die sich ja vor
wenigen Wochen noch gewünscht hat dass
es mit Deutschland bergab geht dass sie
ihr braunes Süppchen hier kochen können
von daher lassen Sie bitte diese Zurufe
und ähm
die Präsidentin die Präsidentin hat ja
zu Beginn der Debatte darauf hingewiesen
dass wir heute Nacht eigentlich bis um 3
Uhr Tagesordnung haben und dass wir uns
alle an unserer Redezeiten halten sollen
eigentlich hätte man sich diese Debatte
sparen können eigentlich hätte man sich
diese Debatte sparen können weil wir
haben diesen Antrag zum
Familiensplitting und den Antrag zu der
Umsatzsteuer genauso vor anderthalb
Jahren hier schon mal im Deutschen
Bundestag diskutiert ich habe mir gerade
die Rednerliste angeschaut und habe so
verglichen mit dem Protokoll die haben
wir sprechen alle wieder jedenfalls die
die damals auch mit dabei waren und das
Ergebnis wird am Schluss nicht anders
als das Ergebnis wird am Schluss nicht
anders sein dass wir diesen Antrag hier
ablehnen und sie haben am Schluss meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kollegen sie haben am Schluss kein
Interesse an der wirklich inhaltlichen
Arbeit an der keine Arbeit die auch hier
zu arbeiten Deutschen Bundestag dazu
gehört dass man sich mal mit Experten
zusammensetzt dass man mal die
Fachliteratur liest dass man auch mal
durchrechnet was ist einzeln bedeutet
und das sieht man daran dass Sie uns
hier copy-pest einfach diesen Antrag
wieder vorlegen so geht es nicht das ist
unseriös
und ich frage mich auch wo sie die
letzten Wochen waren
wir haben doch das Thema Freibeträge
Kinderfreibetrag gerade hier vor wenigen
Wochen diskutiert beim Thema
inflationsausgleichsgesetz da hätten sie
doch zum Beispiel den Änderungsantrag
machen können dass man den
Kinderfreibetrag auf Grundfreibetrag
erhöht haben sie nicht gemacht wir
kommen hier gerade wir kommen hier
gerade aus einer haushaltswoche in der
letzten Woche war haushaltswoche wo
waren eigentlich ihre Anträge um das
ganze hier zu finanzieren haben wir auch
nicht gesehen und insofern kein
Interesse an inhaltlicher Arbeit und
seriös wie sie hier agieren und der
dritte Punkt
und der dritte Punkt hat ja der Kollege
Schrot recht wenn man die beiden Anträge
vergleicht miteinander dann gibt es so
einen großen Unterschied und es ist dass
sie diesmal nicht reingeschrieben haben
was das eigentlich kostet das kostet
67,3 Milliarden Euro wenn man das Thema
Kindergeld noch mit dazu nimmt sind wir
wahrscheinlich bei 70 Milliarden die
diese Maßnahme kostet und dann ist es ja
völlig nochmals unseriös dass sie dann
sagen naja dann sollen mal die
Ministerien eine Prioritätenliste machen
was sozusagen auf Platz 1 steht bis zu
Platz 10 und dann gucken wir was wir
rausschreiben also Leute der
Haushaltsgesetzgeber das sind doch wir
der Haushalt wird in diesem Saal hier im
Plenarsaal verabschiedet da müssen sie
doch mal selber Vorschläge machen wie
sie die 67 Milliarden zusammen kriegen
also auch hier unseriös
und dann ist ja auch die Frage dann ist
ja tatsächlich auch die Frage ist es am
Ende des Tages wirklich so monokausal
dass die Entscheidung für Kinder
irgendwie nur im Steuerrecht hängt und
das glaube ich halt nicht es sind eben
sehr viele andere Dinge es ist
beispielsweise die Frage
Vereinbarkeit von Beruf und Familie und
da haben wir glaube ich einiges zu tun
bei der Frage Kitas wir haben viel zu
wenige Erzieherinnen Erzieher in
Deutschland wir hatten vor wenigen Tagen
vor diesem Tag viele von ihnen werden
auch in ihren Kitas gewesen sein
vorgelesen haben ich habe mit den
Kollegen da vor Ort gesprochen wir haben
zu wenig das sind die Bundesländer
absolut gefragt hier endlich mal mehr zu
tun und ich sag das mal auch als
Rheinland-Pfälzer sagt das mal auch als
Rheinland-Pfälzer da wird in da wird in
einem Gesetz Kita zukunftsgesetz hat
sich das genannt mehr Leistung
versprochen aber es wurde nicht
hinterlegt dann auch mit mehr Erzieherin
die das ganze dann auch abdecken müssen
die Erzieherin Deutschland sind Limit
die Eltern sind auf der Straße und
demonstrieren deswegen rufen wir auch
den Bundesländer zu macht da endlich
mehr aber auch da wo wir gefragt sind
hier im Deutschen Bundestag manche
Programme haben wir ja auch für Kitas
Thema sprachkitas wollten sie zuerst
überhaupt nicht verlängern jetzt ist es
irgendwie in den Haushaltsverhandlungen
noch verlängert worden bis Mitte des
Jahres viele sprachförderkräfte sind
mittlerweile aus den Kitas abgewandert
und das berichten uns die Fachkräfte aus
der Praxis das war sehr schlecht was die
amplian an dieser Stelle gemacht hat
dann
wir hören ja an verschiedenen Stellen
das Politikfelder feministisch
durchdekliniert werden feministische
Außenpolitik feministische
Wirtschaftspolitik Steuerpolitik haben
wir letztes gehört jetzt haben wir
gesehen dass die Familienministerin
Pauls den Vaterschaftsurlaub nach Geburt
der ja zu einer besseren auch Verteilung
zwischen Vater und Mutter wird jetzt
noch mal schiebt dann kommt jetzt nicht
2023 von der EU gefordert sondern erst
ab 24 so geht's nicht wo ist da
eigentlich die feministische
Familienpolitik dieser amtlich sehe sie
nicht letzter Punkt letzter Punkt bei
der Frage
sich für eine Familie zu entscheiden ist
ein ganz wichtiger Punkt auch das Thema
Wohneigentum und die Bilanz die die
Ampel jetzt schon absehbar für die
nächsten Jahre hat ist desaströs beim
Wohneigentum sie wollten jedes Jahr
400.000 neue Wohnungen schaffen so
dieses Jahr sind 250.000 nächstes Jahr
wahrscheinlich nur 200.000 für 2024
prognostiziert weniger als 200.000 das
heißt eines der zentralen Versprechen
von Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz jetzt
schon jetzt schon gebrochen das ist die
Politik der Ampel und
ganz zum Schluss
wir lehnen diesen Antrag natürlich ab
weil es nichts Neues und freuen uns auf
die Diskussionen Finanzausschuss
und nun spricht für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen Sascha Müller
die namentliche Abstimmung ist
eigentlich schon vorbei aber ich frage
noch mal ist jemand im Haus der seine
Stimmkarte noch nicht abgegeben hat
und hier rennt schon jemand
das ist ja eigentlich auch Usus
eigentlich hätte die namentliche
Abstimmung schon vor drei Minuten zu
Ende sein müssen aber jetzt gibt es hier
noch ein paar sportliche Einlagen das
auch die Abgeordneten hier ihre
Stimmkarten einwerfen nein nein also so
gemein bin ich jetzt nicht da warten
noch bis die beiden
ihre Karte ihre Stimmkarte
abgegeben haben die Schriftführer geben
mir mal ein Zeichen
perfekt also die beiden haben abgegeben
dann schließe ich die Abstimmung und
bitte die Schriftführerin und
Schriftführer
auszuzählen und also die
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer
erzählen jetzt aus wie die Abgeordneten
zum Abkommen zwischen der Europäischen
Union und Kanada ceta abgestimmt haben
da werden wir im Laufe des Tages auch
noch die das Ergebnis hören jetzt
spricht Sascha Müller für die Grünen
Fraktion
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen richtig
ist Familien leiden besonders und
aktuellen Situationen mit hohen
Inflationsraten deswegen reagieren die
Bundesregierung und wir als
ampelfraktionen darauf und entlassen in
der Krise gezielt Familien durch die
Anhebung des Kindergeldes auf 250 € für
alle kindergeldberechtigten Kinder ab
dem kommenden Jahr durch die ebenfalls
im inflationsausgleichsgesetz
angepassten Kinderfreibeträge
rückwirkend ab 2022 durch 100 €
Kinderbonus in diesem Jahr durch 20 Euro
im Monat für von Armut betroffene Kinder
als Kinder sofortzuschlag und durch
gestiegene Regelsätze eben auch für
Kinder im Zuge der Einführung des
Bürgergeldes und ganz aktuell im Jahre
Steuergesetz steht morgen die Anhebung
des Entlastungsbetrages für
Alleinerziehende und 252 Euro auf 4.260
Euro zur Abstimmung parallel arbeiten
wir an einer Steuergutschrift für diesen
Personenkreis rund 120 Prozent der
Kinder in Deutschland werden bei
Alleinerziehenden groß das ist also
gewiss kein nischenthemen wir werden
diese Eltern die die Lage versetzen ihre
Familien zu ernähren das sind das sind
Entlastungen die wir schon auf den Weg
gebracht haben auf den Weg bringen
werden dass den Entlastungen die
gebraucht werden das sind Entlastungen
die ankommen und die schließlich helfen
und jetzt kommt die AFD mit dem Antrag
und zum familienspätetigen und will uns
das ein familienspielchen im
Einkommensteuer Tarif als Maßnahme
unterjubeln und Familien zu unterstützen
bzw wenn ich den Antrag lese wird auch
als Mittel zu Erhöhung der Geburtenrate
also wenn ich mir die Zahl der geborene
in Deutschland anschaust liegt in den
letzten Jahren Statistischem Bundesamt
konstant über 700.000 Geburten im Jahr
und ist er gestiegen aber gut was genau
würde so ein Familien was darf den
Zwischenruf habe ich gewartet danke
zeigt ihr für euer Menschenbild okay was
genau würde so ein Familiensplitting
denn bewirken wer profitiert davon ist
das eine Maßnahme die zielgerichtet
familienentlasten soll dass die EW hat
schon 2013 zu der Idee festgestellt dass
die hohen Kosten einer solche Maßnahme
in keinem Verhältnis zum geringen Nutzen
für die beabsichtigten
familienpolitischen Ziele stehen und das
gilt auch heute noch die Gründer
Kindergrundsicherung die unsere
fortschrittskoalition auf den Weg
bringen wird ist die eindeutig
effektivere Maßnahme und Kindern gerade
aus Familien mit geringem Einkommen zu
besseren staatchancen und mehr
Chancengleichheit zu verhelfen so viele
Jahre haben wir dafür gekämpft ich freue
mich drauf
hinzu kommt
hinzu kommt das familienspäteting setzt
auf dem Ehegattensplitting auf und damit
kann diese Debatte auch nicht geführt
werden ohne darauf hinzuweisen dass die
Idee des ehegattes splittings auf dem
aus der Zeit gefallenen Leitbild des
klassischen allein der klassischen
Alleinverdiener eher etwas passiert
das so die traditionelle Arbeitsteilung
in der familiäre Rollenzuweisung
steuerlich subventioniert werden seit
vielen Jahren setzt sich meine Fraktion
dafür ein dass das Ehegattensplitting
für künftige neu geschlossene Ehen
entfallen soll zur Gunsten einer
Individualbesteuerung mit übertragbaren
Freibetrag das würde der heutigen
Lebenswirklichkeit viel besser
entsprechen und Menschen Menschen
deutlich mehr Freiheiten in Bezug auf
Ihr gewünschtes Lebensmodell geben im
Koalitionsvertrag konnten wir uns leider
noch nicht auf diese grundlegende Reform
einigen doch die Zeit dafür wäre reif
was wir aber in dieser Koalition angehen
werden und was wir vereinbart haben im
Koalitionsvertrag ist dass wir für den
Lohnsteuerabzug die Steuerklassen 53 in
das Faktor Verfahren der Steuerklasse 4
überführen werden das hebt die starke
Benachteiligung gerade von Frauen bei
Lohnersatzleistungen auf eigenständige
Existenzsicherung als Grundlage für ein
selbstbestimmtes Leben von Frauen und
Männern ist noch ein entferntes Ziel
dass diese Koalition mit ihrer
gleichstellungsstrategie aber angeht
und Familien brauchen viel mehr als nur
Geld sie brauchen unter anderem flexible
Arbeitszeitmodelle auch ich denke dass
wir dahin kommen müssen dass
beispielsweise
eine 30-Stunden-Woche irgendwann in der
nicht allzu fernen Zukunft für Eltern
von kleinen Kinder ein Leitbild wird und
für kein Elternteil als Karriere
Hindernis gilt mehr als 60 Stunden
bezahlt und unbezahlte Arbeit verrichten
die Eltern kleinere Kinder jüngsten
Erhebungen zufolge das zeigt dass die
Idee einer kürzeren Erwerbsarbeit seit
Wochen nicht nur Utopie sein darf und ja
das zeigt sich hier zeigt sich hier
leicht am redepult dieses Hohen Hauses
und diese Forderung ist zugegeben aus
dem Mund eines Abgeordneten auch ein
Stück paradox angesichts der Realität in
der Politik die nun wirklich keine
familienfreundlichen Arbeitszeiten kennt
und wir hier von diesem Leitbild sehr
weit entfernt sind auch unter uns
Politikerinnen und Politiker täglich ein
Perspektivwechsel wirklich gut
und was noch gebraucht wird
das kehrsystem massiv ausbauen dazu
gehört eine gute und flächendeckend
verfügbare Kinderbetreuung und leider
hat gerade mein Bundesland Bayern hier
erheblichen Nachholbedarf die
Bertelsmann Stiftung hat erst vor
wenigen Wochen ihr ländermonitoring
frühkindliche Bildungssysteme 2022
verpflicht und sie kommt darin zu dem
Schluss dass insbesondere in Bayern
erheblicher Handlungsbedarf besteht die
Zeiten sind alarmierend es müssten
demzufolge 91 ist 61.900 Plätze
geschaffen werden um den Rechtsanspruch
für alle Kinder deren Eltern ein
Betreuungsbedarf haben erfüllen zu
können und laut dem aktuellen Fachkräfte
hat dafür Kita und Grundschule der
Stiftung sieht es für ein ganzes Angebot
an Grundschulen auch nicht gerade gut
aus hier rechnet sie mit einer
erheblichen Fachkräfte Lücke bei der
Kinderbetreuung das erfordert dringend
einen Perspektivwechsel hier müssen wir
einfach besser werden noch einmal alle
Menschen haben nicht alle Menschen haben
die gleichen Bedürfnisse aber Familien
all ihrer Unterschiedlichkeit verdienen
unseren Respekt und Unterstützung
zurück zum Antrag der AFD er greift zu
kurz er ist nicht finanzierbar er setzt
auf ein untaugliches Instrument und vor
allem atmet er den Geist eines
überholten Familienbildes wir werden
diesen Antrag ablehnen
die Ankündigung von Sascha Müller wie
sich hier die Grünen Fraktion Verhalten
wird was die Linken Fraktion sagt das
wird uns nun die Parteivorsitzende der
Linken sagen Janine Wissler
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die AFD fordert ein Familiensplitting im
Steuerrecht angeblich um die Kinderarmut
zu bekämpfen und das ist natürlich ein
ziemlicher Unsinn denn durch das
Splitting profitieren profitieren
natürlich in erster Linie besser
verdiene es profitieren nicht Menschen
die zu Niedriglöhnen arbeiten die so
wenig verdienen dass sie unter den
Grundfreibetrag fallen sie zahlen
nämlich gar keine Steuern oder nur sehr
wenige steuern und wenn sie unter
greifen und Freibetrag sind gar keine
das heißt sie würden dann auch nicht von
Entlastung profitieren und die Menschen
in sozialleistungsbezug profitieren
natürlich erst recht nicht und ich will
das Prinzip des blickings und seine
verteilungswirkung noch mal kurz
erläutern beim Ehegattensplitting werden
die Einkünfte ihr Partner
zusammengerechnet gemeinsam besteuert
wenn also ein Partner gar keinen
Einkommen hat und der andere 30.000 € im
Jahr verdient dann werden beide so
besteuert als würden sie jeweils 15000 €
jährlich verdienen die Lohnsteuer für
beide zusammen beträgt dann ungefähr 110
Euro pro Jahr ohne den splitting Vorteil
würde aber der eine Partner
gar keine und der verdienende Partner
über 3000 Euro Lohnsteuer zahlen das
heißt die Ehepartner verdienen durch das
Splitting etwa 3000 Euro sparen durch
das bildingerter 3000 Euro Steuern pro
Jahr und das kann man bei einem
Jahreseinkommen von 30.000 Euro auch
ganz gut gebrauchen
aber ungerecht wird es eben dann wenn
der eine Partner wenig oder gar nichts
verdient und der andere ein
Spitzeneinkommen hat weil dann spart ein
solches Ehepaar eben nicht 3000 Euro
sondern bis zu 17.700 Euro Steuern und
das ist alles andere als gerecht das ist
schlicht die Verschwendung von
Steuergeld dann ein Konzernchef und
seine nicht verdienende Ehefrau brauchen
diese Steuerersparnis nicht meine Damen
und Herren und es gibt auch werden
vernünftigen Grund Menschen steuerlich
zu fördern nur weil sie geheiratet haben
und erst recht nicht ein Lebensmodell
steuerlich zu fördern bei dem der Mann
sehr viel und die Frau wenig oder nichts
verdient weil sie nicht arbeiten geht
und die dann von ihrem Mann auch immer
wieder erklärt kriegt sie solle auch
nicht arbeiten gehen weil sich das
aufgrund des splittings sowieso nicht
lohne das programmiert Altersarmut vor
das schafft ökonomische Abhängigkeiten
und deshalb sehen wir das
Ehegattensplitting grundsätzlich
Probleme als Problem meine Damen und
Herren
Verdiener zu ihrer reaktionären Frauen
und Familienbild passt und diese
Ungerechtigkeiten die damit verbunden
sind die wollen sie jetzt weiter
ausbauen indem sie reiche Familien
steuerlich noch stärker entlasten wollen
mit dem Kampf gegen Armut oder erst
recht gegen Kinderarmut hat das
überhaupt nichts zu tun was sie hier
machen weil das Familiensplitting ist ja
völlig
falsche gegen Armut was wir brauchen
sind doch keine weiteren
Steuererleichterung verbesserverdiener
was wir brauchen ist eine Kinder
Grundsicherung das ist der richtige Weg
die Forderung von Kindern hat darum
Steuerrecht überhaupt nichts verloren
sonst bleibt es doch ewig bei dem
Prinzip des kinderreicher Familien
steuerlich mehr gefördert werden als
Kinder in armen Familien und die Kinder
Grundsicherung funktioniert genauso
nicht deswegen Sozialverbände
Gewerkschaften andere gesellschaftlicher
Akteure wie als Linke fordern eine
eigenständige Kinder Grundsicherung hat
ja auch Eingang gefunden in den
Koalitionsvertrag und hat dann noch
seiner Umsetzung
und nötig ist genau das nämlich ein
deutlich höheres Kindergeld von etwa 330
Euro pro Monat und darüber hinaus für
ärmere Familien eine Erhöhung dieses
Beitrags auf dieses Betrags auf 630 €.
damit werden die Kinder auch endlich
raus aus diesen ganzen
sanierungssystem das jetzt ab nächstem
Jahr Bürgergeld heißt also meine Damen
und Herren Kinder
brauchenswelt weil es an Personal fehlt
Armut bekämpft man durch tarifreue durch
höhere Mindestlöhne und durch höhere
Sozialleistung was Familien brauchen ist
Arbeitszeitverkürzung die Vereinbarung
von Familie und Beruf durch den Ausbau
von Ganztagsschulen und Kita-Betreuung
alles Dinge wo die AFD immer wieder zum
Schluss hat meine Damen und Herren und
deshalb letzter Satz frau Präsidentin es
geht der AFD eben nicht
umarmungsbekämpfung es geht um die
Rückkehr und Zementierung eines Familien
und Frauen Bildes aus den 50er Jahren
vielen Dank
und der nächste Redner der Bad ist
Markus Herbrand FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren mit dem vorliegenden
Anträgen es handelt sich ja um zwei
Anträge beweist die AFD wieder einmal
ihr besonderes Interesse an sehr
wohlklingenden Forderungen
alles wird der schnellen Schlagzeile
untergeordnet dabei hätten sie vor allem
beim zweiten Antrag im Hinblick auf die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auch die
Möglichkeit gehabt mal mit konkreten
Vorschlägen in die politische Diskussion
einzudringen stattdessen wird monokausal
Weiden in beiden Anträgen auf den
Kostenfaktor Kind verwiesen Kinder seien
ein finanzielles Risiko die sich niemand
mehr leisten können und in der Folge
sind also die Geburtenrate in unserem
Land
worum es ihnen eigentlich geht das hat
ihr reden Beitrag hier noch mal gezeigt
und auch die Begründungen in beiden
Anträgen sie wollten hier das Thema
Migration mal wieder thematisieren und
auch ihre guten Thesen zu irgendwelchen
Reproduktionsraten hier quit werden
unser Menschenbild hier ist ein völlig
anderes
Kinder Kinder werden nicht aus
finanziellen Aspekt Kinder werden nicht
aus finanziellen Aspekten geboren
sondern weiß ich Mann und Frau wünschen
ihre gemeinsame Liebe in ein oder an ein
oder mehrere Kinder weitergeben zu
wollen das sind Liebe
Verantwortungsbewusstsein und die
Zuversicht auf eine tolle gemeinsame
Zeit die den Kinderwunsch nähern und
nicht ein Kontostand
selbstverständlich gehört zu dieser
Verantwortung aber auch dass man die
finanziell Belastungen beachtet
Kinderkosten Geld Kinderkosten sogar
viel Geld dieses Erkenntnis diese
Erkenntnis ist aber nicht neu das
festzustellen dafür bedarf ist Anträge
der AFD nun wirklich nicht ebenso klar
wie die Tatsache dass Kindergeld Kosten
ist aber auch dass wir in unserem Land
massive Anstrengungen unternehmen um
sowohl die finanziellen als auch
sonstige Belastungen für Eltern
bestmöglich abzufedern aus der langen
Liste staatlicher Leistungen auf Bundes-
[Musik]
250 Euro pro Monat und Kind einheitlich
diese und andere Aufwendungen
in Milliardenhöhe mögen manchen zu
gering erscheinen allerdings ist die
Ausfinanzierung beliebig viele Kinder
jetzt auch nicht unbedingt Aufgabe des
Staates und der Gesellschaft wir müssen
und wollen in den Fällen unterstützen in
denen Hilfe notwendig ist und Kindern
und Eltern ein chancenreiches und freies
Leben zu ermöglichen denn bei allem
Unsinn den die AFD in ihren Anträgen
schreibt hat sie doch bei einer Sache
recht Kinder und uns nachfolgende
Generationen sind die Zukunft unseres
Landes denn sie sind der unverzichtbare
Eckpfeiler für die Tragfähigkeit unserer
Sozialsysteme von der Rente bis zur
Gesundheitsversorgung Staat und
Gesellschaft müssen daher unbedingt
dafür Sorge tragen dass die Kinder
Bildungs- und Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
erhalten und dass sie am Ende des Tages
einen Beitrag zum Fortbestand unseres
Landes leisten können diesem Anspruch
werden Bund und Länder Kommunen bei
aller Kritik der bestehenden Strukturen
seit Jahrzehnten bereits gerecht aber
gesellschaftliche Rahmenbedingungen
verändern sich und deshalb muss auch der
Staat reagieren deswegen hat die Ampel
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
eine Kindergrundsicherung auf den Weg zu
bringen und die Vereinbarkeit von
Familie und Beruf weiter zu erleichtern
wir werden unter anderem auch die
Steuerklasse 5 abschaffen
zum zweiten Antrag der bei der von der
AFD geforderten Mehrwertsteuersenkung
für Kinderartikel kann ich jetzt nicht
mit einem sinnvollen gegen Entwurf der
Ampel dienen und zwar alleine deswegen
weil dieser Vorschlag wirklich jenseits
von gut und böse ist
schon die Abgrenzungsfragen alleine was
unter Artikel des kinderbedarfs und
diesbezügliche Dienstleistungen fallen
ist maximal herausfordernd ist da die
Kinderschokolade schon dabei
kann der
Geigenunterricht auch von Erwachsenen
wahrgenommen werden ab welcher Größe
sind T-Shirts nur für Kinder nutzbar und
wann wird es für modebewusste Erwachsene
auch noch interessant also speziell
speziell die zweite speziell die zweite
Initiative hätten sich wirklich besser
in ihren prall gefüllten Peinlichkeiten
Ordner einsortieren sollen und auch die
der Antrag zum familienstätigen der ist
jetzt weder ausgereift noch wird er dem
gerecht was in Deutschland schon
geschieht was wir heute schon für
Familien leisten darüber hinaus werden
wir halt als Ampel da auch noch Dinge
aus dem koalitionsverfahren umsetzen
damit die Modernität in unserer
Gesellschaft und in der Verwaltung auch
noch bei den Familien besser ankommt
diese Anträge sind selbstverständlich
abzulegen herzlichen Dank
und bevor ich die nächsten Redner
Aufrufe möchte ich das Ergebnis der
namentlichen Abstimmung bekannt geben
zum
Abkommen
abgegebene Stimmkarten
669 mit ja haben gestimmt
559 mit Nein haben gestimmt 110 es gab
Null Enthaltungen der Gesetzentwurf ist
damit angenommen
also mehr als 13 Jahre nach Start der
Verhandlung hat nun hier der Deutsche
Bundestag diesen Gesetzentwurf
angenommen und damit kommen wir wieder
zurück zur Debatte zum Familiensplitting
auf Anträgen der AFD und für die AFD
spricht Union König sehr geehrte
Kollegen und vor allem liebe Familien
vorab erstmal Liebe SPD lieber Herr
schrodi seit 100 Jahren regiert die SPD
in diesem Land mit und das Ergebnis ist
dass jedes fünfte Kind in Armut lebt
das Schreiben sich mal hinter die Ohren
so Deutschlands Wirtschaft hat sich in
den letzten 60 bis 80 Jahren am ständige
Zuwanderung gewöhnt zuerst kamen 14
Millionen Deutsche als Kriegsflüchtlinge
aus dem Osten dann sorgte die DDR bis
1961 für ein ständigen Zustrom gut
ausgebildeter Leute nach dem Mauerbau
war damit Schluss und man begann bei
anderen Völkern nach Arbeitskräften zu
suchen Italiener Spanier Griechen Türken
Jugoslawen und viele andere kamen nach
der Maueröffnung ging das ganze mit den
Osteuropäern weiter und es wurden alle
die mal irgendeinen deutschen im
Stammbaum hatten ins Land geholt
ab 2015 hat man die Staatsgrenzen
aufgegeben und Syrer Afghanen und
Nordafrikaner in Massen hereingelassen
in der Tendenz wurden die Zuwanderer
immer Kultur ferner in dieser langen
Zeit haben die Deutschen verlernt
genügend eigene Kinder zu bekommen und
aufwachsen zu lassen heute haben wir
fast 40 Prozent der Kinder mit
Migrationshintergrund eine Gesellschaft
die so viel Zuwanderung zulässt
entwickelt sich nicht mehr nein sie wird
von außen verändert
die propagierte Lösung der alten
Parteien besteht darin einfach weiter
alle reinzulassen und dann zu hoffen
dass die benötigten Fachkräfte unter den
massenhaft zugewenderten sind wir sollen
also einfach die Kinder und Jugend von
anderen Völkern wegnehmen und damit
diese für uns arbeiten wir nehmen also
anderen Ländern die Fachkräfte aus
völlig egoistischen Gründen weg
diese Politik ist man muss sozusagen sie
ist parasitär fakt ist es kommen aber
mehrheitlich keine Fachkräfte sondern
Profiteure unseres Sozialstaates
[Musik]
eine Frage wurde fast nie gestellt warum
haben wir in Deutschland eigentlich zu
wenig Kinder das ist ganz einfach zu
erklären Kinder sind in einer
industriellen Eigentumsgesellschaft für
den Erwerb von Eigentum und Geld eher
hinderlich dafür sie Geld Zeit und
Ressourcen benötigt werden Kinder sind
in einem Sozialstaat mit
Rentenversicherung a eine
Einkommensquelle für die
transferabhängige Unterschicht B ein
finanzielles Risiko für die
Mittelschicht und C kein Problem für die
Oberschicht in der Unterschicht haben
wir inzwischen Hartz IV Dynastien mit
vielen Kindern die Mittelschicht
verzichtet häufig aus finanziellen
Gründen auf ein zweites und drittes Kind
und die Oberschicht bekommt so viele
Kinder wie sie möchte die Lösung der
Alternative für Deutschland ist eine
humana Alternative zum parasitären
Menschen Diebstahl der alten Parteien
die Lösung heißt mehr Kinder dafür daher
wollen wir mit unseren Anträgen zu
Familiensplitting die Familien mit zwei
und drei Kinder finanziell besser
Stellen kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss
Single und zwei Verdiener ohne Kinder
Herr König
zum Schluss wenn uns in der
Familienpolitik keine kehren kehrwände
gelingt dann hat Tilo Sarrazin recht
gehabt und Deutschland schafft sich ab
vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
der König war das wurde hier noch mal
erwähnt schon vorher hatte ja auch viel
zu Präsidentin Petra Paul des Deutschen
Bundestags er meint es wird heute ein
langer Tag für die Abgeordneten Leni
breimeier jetzt für die SPD-Fraktion
von 100.000 Euro im Jahr bekommen zahlt
keine Steuern mehr hört sich nicht an
ist aber hinterhältig die AFD
missbraucht den Begriff Familie um die
Gleichberechtigung zu untergraben sie
will das Ehegattensplitting erweitern
und nehmt dies wohl klingend
Familiensplitting neu ist das nicht
wirklich es folgt natürlich ohne
irgendeine Nähe zu vermuten total
zufällig der nationalsozialistischen
Ideologie mit Hilfe von Steuerpolitik
Frauen aus dem Erwerbsleben
fernzuhalten und die Worte die sie in
ihren Reden benutzen unterstreichen das
auch das kommt aus der rechten Ecke alle
paar Jahre hoch wie das Ungeheuer von
Loch Ness von ganz unten mit
Berücksichtigung der wechselseitigen
Unterhaltsverpflichtungen wollen wir das
Ehegattensplitting abschaffen weil es
die Partnerin in aller Regel mit
geringem Einkommen gerade zu motiviert
keiner bezahlten und sozialversicher
Erwerbsarbeit nachzugehen ist
unterstützt das überholte Familienbild
die Frau kümmert sich um Kinder um Küche
und manchmal auch noch um Kirche da
viele Leute keine
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage des
Kollegen Gottschalk aus der afd-fraktion
Steuer bezahlen weil sie schlicht zu
wenig Lohn haben würden ihnen eine
weitere Steuersenkung durch
Familiensplitting eben nicht helfen für
hohe Einkommen wäre es aber eine
deutliche und spürbare Steuersenkung
allerdings würde sich der fiskalische
Effekt also Steuer Mindereinnahmen mit
denen dann fehlenden Geld für Betreuung
Grippe Kita Schulen und so weiter
kreuzen wir haben es gehört über 67
Milliarden Euro würden fehlen dafür und
am Ende würde noch verstärkt was wir
jedenfalls nicht wollen Kinder und
Frauen bleiben zu Hause das ist der
eigentliche Hintergrund des afd-antrags
alles ziemlich durchschaubar in
Deutschland werden Ehepaare derzeit
gemeinsam besteuert dazu dadurch
entsteht ein splitting-vorteil der umso
größer ist je weiter die Einkommen
auseinanderlegen
ich war letzte Woche bei einem Vortrag
von Marcel Fratzscher von Professor
Fratscher beim deutschen Frauenrat und
der hat ziemlich glasklar dargestellt
wie sich die Elemente der gemeinsamen
Besteuerung also auch unser
Ehegattensplitting wie sich das in den
einkommensteuergesetzen von 17
europäischen Ländern und auch den USA
auswirken es ist so je mehr gemeinsam
besteuert wird desto weniger
erwerbsarbeitsstunden haben die Frauen
das sind in Belgien zum Beispiel 339
Stunden weniger im Jahr in Deutschland
279 Stunden und in Norwegen die nämlich
kein splitting haben oder wenig
splitting haben das ins 38 Stunden und
in Schweden sind zum Beispiel 0 alleine
durch das Ehegattensplitting arbeiten
die Frauen hierzulande fast 280 Stunden
weniger im Jahr was das für den Arbeits
für den Fachkräftemangel für den
Arbeitskräftemangel heißt das muss ich
wohl hier nicht erklären aber ich aber
was ich schon erklären will ist was das
für die Renten der Frauen heißt in
Estland und beträgt die Rentenlücke
zwischen Frauen und Männern zwei Prozent
in Dänemark sieben Prozent in
Großbritannien 34 und in Deutschland 37
Prozent und das sind auch Auswirkungen
dieser
steuersplitting Gesetzgebung und deshalb
können wir irgendwann mal womöglich froh
sein wir hätten hier ein paar
Zuwanderinnen und Zuwanderer die auch
mal unsere rentenzahlen meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es bringt uns
hier nicht wirklich weiter reiche zu
bevorzugen wir sind auf dem richtigen
Weg mit dem Ganztag in der Grundschule
mit der Erhöhung des Kindergelds mit
dabeibehaltung der Kinderfreibeträge mit
der Kindergrundsicherung das sind diese
Themen an denen wir arbeiten das sind
die Themen die Familien vorwärts bringen
Familiensplitting das hört sich nett an
aber nett ist halt doch nur die kleine
Schwester von sie wissen schon wir
wollen mit dem steuerrechtseinkommen
möglichst gerecht besteuern und nicht
rollen verteilen also ist es klar dass
wir den Antrag ablehnen wie letztes Mal
und künftig können wir eigentlich
hergehen und die Reden aus der AFD im
Protokoll vom letzten Mal gruppieren
einfügen können und viel Zeit ersparen
soweit die Sprecherin für Familie
Senioren Frauen und Jugend jetzt gibt es
eine Kurzintervention aus der AFD Kai
Gottschalk meldet sich zu Wort
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
breimeier insoweit war ihre Rede nett
wenn ich da dann ihre Riese aufnehmen
darf aber ich weiß nicht lesen bildet
und es gilt auch für die
Sozialdemokraten wo steht in diesem
Antrag und wenn sie von einem splitting
ausgehen oder einer zusammenfallanlage
und bei ihr Leuten dass wir nicht wollen
dass Frauen arbeiten gehen wir wollen
natürlich das Frauen arbeiten gehen aber
wir wollen und das ist der Punkt das
auch Menschen die entsprechend beide
erwerbstätig sind sich Kinder noch
leisten können ist jemand ihre Klientel
in Baden-Württemberg mit einem
Durchschnittseinkommen im Jahr dort
liegt das Durchschnittseinkommen etwa
bei 49.000 € würden Sie sagen dass es
reich und ist jemand wirklich reich dann
wenn er dann drei Kinder hat wir haben
nämlich gesagt und das haben sie ja eben
auch weggelassen ab dem dritten Kind
sind 100000 € zu versteuerndes Einkommen
entsprechend dann auf freizustellen das
haben wir gesagt nichts hinaus wissen
Sie was bei mir in NRW in Kitaplatz
kostet gerade für diese Familien die sie
oder die Menschen die sie mit dem
Durchschnittseinkommen als reich
bezeichnen
431 Euro im Monat das kostet
durchschnittlich ein Kitaplatz für
Menschen die arbeiten das sind mehr als
8.000 Euro im Jahr eigentlich sind sie
hier die Spalter sie wollen nämlich in
Wirklichkeit gar keine Kinder
wahrscheinlich von Menschen die arbeiten
gehen und die Selbstständigen die
Steuern zahlen die ihrer Klientel die
für die sie sich so gerne gerieren hier
was sie gar nicht mehr sind
Arbeitsplätze anbieten das sind auch
Menschen die Erwerbseinkommen erzielen
zwar auf eine andere Einkommen aber ich
glaube das haben sie vergessen und sie
haben auch vergessen dass wir nach dem
neuesten OECD Bericht die höchste Steuer
und Abgabenlast haben da ist es an der
Zeit die Menschen mal zu entlasten die
zu arbeiten gehen verdammt noch mal
damit sie vielleicht und mein Kollege
hat gesagt die Kinder sich auch leisten
können und das hat nichts entscheiden
und so weit bleibe ich dabei ihr Vortrag
war nett das war ist aber auch
und Frau palmaier sie haben die
Möglichkeit zu antworten
ja Gottschalk muss schon blöd sein wenn
man von seiner Fraktion keine Redezeit
kriegt und dann kurz Interventionen
nutzen muss um das raus zu blasen was
man die ganze Zeit eigentlich sagen
wollte aber was was ich Ihnen sagen will
ich Steuern steuern und was wir mit der
Steuergesetzgebung macht hat nicht nur
Auswirkungen auf die Geldbeutel der
Menschen sondern hat auch Auswirkungen
darauf wie die Menschen erleben
gestalten wie sie erwerbstätig sind mit
wie viel Stunden sie erwerbstätig sind
oder nicht und das Ehegattensplitting
und ist von Ihnen vorgeschlagene
Familiensplitting führt dazu oder würde
noch mehr dazu führen dass der Mann mit
seinem höheren Einkommen dann eben
arbeiten geht in Vollzeit und die Frauen
nicht steuern steuern und die Frauen
verdienen nicht mehr als die Männer
jedenfalls nicht im Schnitt der Gender
Payback ist bei uns immer noch bei 18%
und den Rest beim zum ersten Mal ich
mache mit Ihnen hier keine nebendebatte
auf
Leni breymaier war das hier und bei ihr
hat man es besonders gesehen heute das
Welt AIDS Tags seit 1988 wird er am 1
Dezember begangen und deswegen haben wir
einige Abgeordneten eine Schleife
angesteckt
stehen das Eltern und Kinder aber auch
die alleinerziehende Mutter und Vater
die wichtigste Grundlage unserer
Gesellschaft und die Voraussetzung für
ein Gelingen unsere Zivilgesellschaft
und deswegen legen wir nicht umsonst als
CDU und CSU besonderen Wert auf eine
christliche Prägung der Politik die
Familie als Kern ansieht und liebe
Kollegen von der SPD Michael schrodi
Frau bremmeier oder auch Sascha Müller
von den Grünen es steht uns glaube ich
nicht zu
vorzuschreiben wie die Familien
entscheiden und zu sagen wenn eine
Mutter zu Hause ist oder Hausfrau ist
despektierlich so zu sprechen sondern
die Familien müssen immer noch die
eigene Entscheidung treffen können wie
sie ihre Miteinander in der Familie wie
sie die Arbeitsaufteilung und wie sie
die auch die einkommensaufteilung machen
deswegen keine klaren politischen
Vorgaben was zu tun ist es ist die
Freiheit der Familien und da kann man
nicht sagen es ist eine halt hergebracht
des Modell oder ein old fashion Modell
sondern die Familien entscheiden und es
ist richtig wichtig ist dass die Kinder
gut aufwachsen das ist das Ziel und
deswegen kann ich auch nur sagen im
afd-antrag steht ja drin Kinder sind
kein Sinn ein Kostenfaktor und ich kann
ihnen bloß sagen auch als eigener
Erfahrung Kinder sind ein wunderbares
Geschenk und ein wahrer Luxus und kein
Kostenfaktoren das ist eine falsche
Betrachtungsweise wir müssen uns kümmern
dass wir alle Wege die die Familie
beschreiten alle Wege unterstützen damit
Kinder aufwachsen Bildung haben und in
die Gesellschaft kommen und während ich
so auf die Formulierung oder die
Zusendung des Antrages gewartet habe
habe ich mal ein bisschen geguckt
im drucksachenarchiv um nach dem
ähnlichen Antrag der AFD zu suchen und
ich musste feststellen täglich grüßt das
Murmeltier so wie die Linke immer den
Antrag auf Vermögenssteuer stellt so
kommen sie immer wieder mit dem Antrag
Ehegatten Familiensplitting doch beide
Anträge sind durch permanente wieder
schon nicht unbedingt besser ein Blick
ist übrigens auch nicht viel
substanziell neues dazugekommen sie
haben ein Gutachten aus dem Jahr 2013
als Studie herangezogen also keine neuen
Fakten die es wert wären überhaupt auch
über das Thema was durchaus interessant
ist auch zu sprechen in Deutschland
haben wir ein funktionierendes System
aus Ehegattensplitting Grundfreibetrag
Kinderfreibetrag und Kindergeld
und wenn man ihrem Antrag ein Stück
näher kommt und des
kindersplittingmodell anguckt dann
vergleichen Sie das in Stuttgart mit
Frankreich in Frankreich haben die
ersten zwei Kinder 0,5 splitting
sozusagen als eine vierköpfige Familie
hat einen Faktor von drei und jedes
weitere Kind hat einen splitting-faktor
mehr aber schaut mal in die Statistik
also vergleicht man sozusagen die
Entlastungen zwischen Frankreich und
Deutschland dann sieht man das unser
System bestehend eben aus
ehegattenfreibetrag Kindergeld mehr
Entlastung bringt als das System in
Frankreich und deswegen bleiben wir auch
bei diesem System was wir in Deutschland
haben
und sie impliziert trotzdem weiterhin
das sozusagen diese Splitt im Modell
besser wäre so wie sie es anlegen
entlastet es nicht die alleinerziehende
Mutter entlastet aber auch nicht die
Familie mit niedrigem Einkommen und
vielen Kindern sondern hat einen
Fehlanreiz deswegen wenn wir darüber
diskutieren dann müssen wir schauen dass
wir gerade die Familien mit vielen
Kindern und niedrigen Einkommen
entlasten und wir haben übrigens
Freibetrag für das Jahressteuergesetz
2022 eine wesentlich höhere Entlastung
gefordert als die ampelfraktion jetzt
umsetzt wir haben das ja im letzten Jahr
wesentlich erhöht das haben sie
abgelehnt also wir hätten gerne
Alleinerziehende Freibetrag auf 5000
Euro angehoben aber das haben sie
abgelehnt also wenn sie von Entlastungen
sprechen dann sollten Sie es auch
umsetzen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Ampel die Ampel hat ja angekündigt
dass das Ehegattensplitting bald
Geschichte sein wird so stets zumindest
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag nach den
heutigen reden habe ich ein bisschen
denken dass sie trotzdem politische
Vorgaben machen wie Familie
durchzuführen ist und das darf nicht
sein ich kann das nur wiederholen die
Familien sollen die Freiheit haben zu
entscheiden wie sie ihr Leben gestalten
und alle Wege sind die richtigen Wege
deswegen glaube ich sollten wir da keine
politischen Vorgaben machen und
vielleicht ein letzter Aspekt
zu dem antragssenkung der Umsatzsteuer
auf Kinderartikel und so weiter auf 7
Prozent wir brauchen Kollege Künstler
ist ja auch schon bei den
umsatzsteuerreden immer wieder erwähnt
richtigerweise wir brauchen eine
ehrliche Diskussion darüber wie dieser
Flickenteppich Umsatzsteuer sozusagen
gestaltet werden kann und wie wir hier
eine klare Linie reinbringen und wenn
wir Familien weiter entlasten wollen
dann können wir das konsequenter mit den
bestehenden Steuersystem machen und wir
haben Stellschrauben die leider die
Ampel leider nicht in dem in der Weise
nutzt zum Beispiel hätten wir die kalte
Progression schon im Jahr 2022 abmildern
können hat die Ampel leider nicht
vorgenommen wir hätten eine weitere
Abflachung des Steuertarifs vornehmen
können wir hätten eine weitere
Abflachung des Steuertarifs durch
abbautes mittelstandsbaus machen können
haben sie nicht vorgenommen also wenn
wir hier auch die Debatte ich habe es
gerade erwähnt um den Alleinerziehenden
Freibetrag die Erhöhung haben sie nicht
vorgenommen also wenn wir was tun wollen
für Familien mit Kindern haben wir genug
Möglichkeiten wir können die gerne
angehen ich freue mich auf eine
Diskussion im Finanzausschuss über die
verschiedenen Möglichkeiten wir müssen
die Familien mit Kindern weiter voll im
Blick haben denn sie sind die Zukunft
unseres Landes die Kinder und brauchen
unsere Unterstützung und deswegen
Freiheit für die Familien zu entscheiden
wie sie es umsetzen ich freue mich auf
die Diskussionen die Anträge lehnen wir
aus den genannten Gründen
und für Bündnis 90 die Grünen hat das
Wort dr wolfgang strengmann Kuhn
sehr geehrter frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen sehr geehrter Herr Kollege
Bremen es gibt in Deutschland eine große
Vielfalt an Familienformen sehr bunt
sehr vielfältig und das ist super gut
das ist so ist und es ist auch richtig
dass Eltern Väter und Mütter entscheiden
ob sie arbeiten wie viel Sie arbeiten
die Freiheit sollen und müssen sie haben
das ist genau unser Menschenbild und ich
glaube das eint alle fast alle
Fraktionen hier im Bundestag da gibt es
keinen Unterschied Herr Bremen wir
setzen auf die Freiheit der Eltern aber
wo ist ein Unterschied gibt ist wir
wollen nicht einseitig bestimmte
Familienbilder finanziell fördern
sondern das ist der zentrale Punkt und
deswegen wollen wir Grüne im Gegensatz
zu Union dass jetzige System sie haben
es eben beschrieben das
Familienleistungsausgleich mit Ehegatten
Kinder
weltkinderfreibeträgen grundlegend
ändern und deswegen ist bei uns auch
nach wie vor auf der Agenda und im
Programm das wäre das Ehegattensplitting
ersetzen wollen durch eine
Individualbesteuerung weil durch das
ehegattenspetting werden hohe Einkommen
bevorzugt das ist ungerecht es ist eben
nicht
unabhängig von dem Familientyp sondern
wir wollen eine Förderung die unabhängig
vom Familienstatus der Eltern ist und
das Ehegattensplitting setzt falsche
Anreize für Frauen und deswegen wollen
wir das Ehegattensplitting gerne weg
haben
und was die Anreize betrifft wird die
Ampel noch einen wichtigen Schritt gehen
nämlich die Lohnsteuerklasse 5
abschaffen das ist ein wichtiger Schritt
um negativer Arbeitsanreize für Frauen
zu beseitigen um mehr Gleichstellung
zwischen Männern und Frauen hinzukriegen
die Ampel wird da aktiv werden
und vor allen Dingen werden wir als
Ampel eine Kindergrundsicherung
einführen und das nicht irgendwann
sondern wir haben ja schon Schritte
getan wir haben den Kindern
sofortzuschlag eingeführt 20 Euro mehr
für Menschen mit Familien mit geringen
Einkommen wir haben beschlossen dass
Kindergeld zu erhöhen ab 1 Januar die
größte Kindergelderhöhung die es
überhaupt gibt auf 250 Euro und das ist
ein großer Schritt hin zu dem
garantiebetrag der im
Koalitionsvertrag verabredeten
Kindergrundsicherung dieser
garantiebetrag soll alle Kinder
unabhängig vom Einkommen ihrer Eltern
erhalten im Koalitionsvertrag steht das
Ziel künftig allein durch den
garantiebetrag den
verfassungsrechtlichen Vorgaben nach
Freistellung des kindlichen
Existenzminimums bei der Besteuerung des
elterneinkommens zu entsprechen das Ziel
ist noch nicht erreicht noch immer
bekommen Eltern die ein Einkommen haben
also die Bundestagsabgeordnete oder noch
höheres Einkommen mehr für ihre Kinder
als Eltern mit mittleren Einkommen das
halten wir für ein großes
gerechtigkeitsproblem aber mit der
Einhebung auf 250 Euro haben wir diese
Gerechtigkeitslücke verringert und der
Grünen würden da gerne noch weitergehen
und da werden wir in der Koalition im
Rahmen der Kindergrundsicherung noch
drüber reden gibt es zwei Stellschrauben
entweder ein noch höherer garantiebetrag
oder wir diskutieren über den
sogenannten bea-freibetrag von dem die
reicheren vor allen Dingen profitieren
dass wir eine Möglichkeit dass Menschen
mit hohem Einkommen eine geringere
Förderung von ihrer für ihre Kinder
kriegen auch das wäre ein gerechter
Schritt da werden wir mit dem
Finanzminister noch mal drüber zu
diskutieren haben und auch mit dem
Koalitionspartner von der SPD der für
uns aber ein wichtiger Punkt
neben dem garantiebetrag gibt es aber
noch den zweiten Baustein in der
Kindergrundsicherung wenn es um die
Menschen mit geringem Einkommen geht den
nennen wir Zusatzbetrag für Kinder mit
Eltern mit geringem Einkommen und da
sind für uns zwei Punkte besonders
wichtig
wichtig vor allen Dingen Gegensatz zum
jetzigen System muss man ja bei dem
System in Anführungszeichen sagen ist
das eine automatische Auszahlung gibt
oder zumindest weitgehend automatische
Auszahlung jetzt haben wir ja das
Phänomen dass viele Leistungen gar nicht
in Anspruch genommen werden weil die
bürokratischen Hürden zu groß sind weil
die Leute das gar nicht wissen dass sie
diese Leistungen bekommen und deswegen
ist es wichtig dass nicht die Menschen
zu den Leistungen gehen sondern die
Leistungen zu den Menschen kommen und
die Leute das ohne Anspruch ohne große
Bürokratie in Anspruch nehmen können und
die Leistung bekommen die ihnen ja auch
zusteht automatische Auszahlung ein ganz
zentraler Punkt der Kindergrundsicherung
und der zweite Punkt ist im
Koalitionsvertrag steht dass wir das
Existenzminimum neu definieren wollen
und da sind uns die 20 Euro sofort zu
schlagen noch nicht
ausreichend dafür würden wir gerne noch
drauflegen da ist das BMAS gefordert
einen Vorschlag vorzulegen im Rahmen der
Diskussion das wird auch noch mal ein
wichtiger Punkt werden weil das
bisherige Leistung für Menschen mit
geringem Einkommen reicht nicht aus da
brauchen wir mehr man sieht die Ampel
ist tatkräftig dabei
zu stellen und ein Existenzminimum für
Menschen mit geringem Einkommen zu
garantieren und Menschen mit mittleren
Einkommen finanziell zu unterstützen
vielen Dank
so damit kommen wir zum nächsten Redner
hier in dieser Debatte zum sogenannten
Familiensplitting das ist Maximilian
Mordhorst FDP-Fraktion liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ein schlechter Antrag der
AFD ist je mehrfach zur Sprache gekommen
drei krude reden die wir gehört haben
die Leistungsbilanz der Herren König
Reichert und gottschalk ist das beste
Beispiel und das beste Argument dafür
dass es vollkommen in Ordnung in diesen
Zeiten ist dass auch der Mann mal zu
Hause bleibt und die kehrarbeit erledigt
dass wir moderner werden denn es gibt
keinen qualitativen Unterschied
zwischen Männern und Frauen zumindest im
Regelfall und erst recht nicht nur wegen
ihres Geschlechtes wir sind deswegen auf
genau dem richtigen Weg dabei das
Steuersystem in diesem Bereich zu
modernisieren leistungsgerecht zu machen
nicht Anreize zu setzen dass eines der
beiden Geschlechter nur zu Hause bleibt
sondern dass man selbst entscheidet wer
das machen möchte zweitens
zweitens wir haben ein großes Problem
dabei dass in ihren in ihren Reden die
Menschen die hierzulande arbeiten oder
die einheimisch sind die deutsche
Staatsbürger sind gegen Einwanderer
ausgespielt werden dass es genau der
falsche Weg ich bin jedem dankbar der
sich hier entscheidet eine Familie zu
gründen genauso wenig wie ich jedem
dankbar bin der hierherkommt und sich
etwas aufzubauen die Sprache lernen sich
an die Regeln hält das ist genau der
richtige Weg und deswegen bin ich froh
dass wir einen Einwanderungsgesetz auf
den Weg bringen auch gegen ihre Kunden
Stimmen drittens bei der Mehrwertsteuer
sehen wir eher Unregelmäßigkeiten schon
bisherigen Systemen die zu komischen
Ergebnis führen wir haben dort eher auf
Vereinheitlichung setzen statt mit so
einem komischen Begriff wie Artikel des
kinderbedarfs Kollege Herbrand hat
darauf hingewiesen noch mehr
Unregelmäßigkeiten in das System zu
bringen und viertens das angepeilte
tagungsende für heute ist 3.25 Uhr und
deswegen schenke ich Ihnen die letzten
zwei Minuten Redezeit und hoffe dass
andere mein Beispiel folgen
[Applaus]
und für die Unionsfraktion hat das Wort
dr hermann Josef teproke Hermann Joseph
ist jetzt im Ausschuss für Familie
Senioren Frauen und Jugend
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren vor allem liebe
Familien
entlasten keine Familie darf auf der
Strecke bleiben sie sind die beiden
Anträge die hier vorliegen überschrieben
und ich kann sagen werde das nicht ich
gehe fest davon aus dass es darüber eine
Einigkeit hier im Plenum gibt alle
wollen dafür sorgen dass Familien
entlastet werden und keine Familie auf
der Strecke bleiben
wenn
aber ist das auch das vorrangige Motiv
der Antragsteller
im Antrag ist man davon die Rede dass
man den Gründen entgegenwirken möge
weswegen Menschen sich gegen ihren
eigentlichen wünschen gegen Kinder
entscheiden wenn ich jetzt aber die
Wortbeiträge jetzt aus der Debatte
höhere habe ich erhebliche Zweifel ob
das das vorrangige Motiv ist und zum
zweiten im Antrag wird deutlich gemacht
es ginge darum die finanzielle Armut in
Familien zu bekämpfen sehe aber das
Instrumente vorgeschlagen wenn in einer
Variante durch die gerade nicht die
belasteten Familien in besonderer Weise
berücksichtigt werden sondern diejenigen
die Einkommen stärker sind darum meine
Zweifel an der aufrichtigen Motivation
der Antragsteller
meine Damen und Herren aber positiv
gewendet an dieser Stelle ich bin froh
und dankbar darüber dass wir eine
Debatte Familienpolitik hier heute
Nachmittag führen können es ist wichtig
dass wir auf dieser Gelegenheit nutzen
den Familien mehr Aufmerksamkeit und
Anerkennung
zukommen zu lassen wir brauchen ein
wertschätzendes Umfeld wir brauchen eine
Willkommenskultur Familien brauchen
Infrastruktur sie brauchen Zeit
füreinander und sie brauchen
finanziellen Spielraum und darauf stellt
der Antrag zum Wort sind ab und das soll
auch dass diejenige was ich in der Sache
ansprechen möchte sein
familiensplittung welche Variante Sie
haben sich offensichtlich für die
Familien
tarifing-variante entschieden warum
nicht die real,- Variante dazu sagt der
Antrag nicht ich hätte auch gerne mehr
erfahren darüber wie sie die zellung der
Kinder für den Divisor vornehmen 051,0
sind gerade schon diskutiert worden
einige Berechnungen die sie anstellen
lassen haben durch die Bundesregierung
kommen auf
wenn man die 100.000 steuerfrei stellen
will in jedem Fall aber das ist der
wichtige Punkt profitieren insbesondere
Einkommen starke Familien von diesem
Modell und das ist eben angesichts des
erklärt Motivs etwas problematisch man
könnte Obergrenzen einführen was die
steuerlichen Effekte angeht darüber
sagen sie gar nichts wäre auch dann
natürlich intransparenter schwieriger
vielleicht zu kommunizieren erstaunlich
sie halten am Kindergeld fest in welcher
Höhe 250 € 300 man könnte auch
argumentieren in Höhe der maximalen
Entlastung die durch einen
Kinderfreibetrag sie gehen auf einen
Grund fallbetrag resultieren könnten ist
das so damit jeder was davon hat
jedenfalls eine günstiger Prüfung findet
nicht statt und das begünstigt natürlich
wieder insbesondere die Einkommen
stärkeren Gruppen warum das meine Damen
und Herren und last but not least die
Kosten die mit einem solchen Projekt
verbunden sind werden nicht expliziert
darauf haben meine Vorrednerinnen
bereits zehn gewesen
30 bis 40 Milliarden sagen erste
Schätzung andere Schätzungen auf 70
Milliarden hängt natürlich davon ab wie
diese Variante des Familienmodells genau
des familiensplittingsmodells genau
ausgestaltet wird darüber haben wir eben
noch viel zu wenig Erfahrung
ist das denn am Ende gerecht auch
gerecht gegenüber allen Familien was sie
da Vorhaben ist das am Ende wirksam und
vor allem ist es effizient ich habe
junge Familien oder Familien auch mit
jüngeren Kindern aber ich habe auch
junge Erwachsenen vor Augen die sagen
ist ja alles gut und schön wenn ihr euch
da solche Schaufenster Projekte ausdenkt
aber ist ja sichergestellt dass die
Gegenfinanzierung funktioniert da wird
immer gesagt man sparen anderer Stelle
oder ist das am Ende des Tages nicht
doch wieder eine Neuverschuldung und wer
zahlt denn die Kapital Dienste dieser
neuen Verschuldung von sagen wir mal 70
Milliarden pro Jahr das sind doch wieder
wir ist das Familien und
kinderfreundlich wenn diese Fragen nicht
abschließend geklärt sind solche
großartigen Projekte hier aufzublasen
ich finde die jungen Menschen haben
recht
meine Damen und Herren wir haben als
Union sehr wohl die Auffassung dass man
steuerpolitisch auch agieren muss wenn
man familienpolitisch aktiv sein wollten
will und da widerspreche ich Ihnen Frau
Wissler sie haben eine andere Auffassung
vertreten Familienpolitik ist eben nicht
nur Sozialpolitik auch Sozialpolitik
aber auch Steuerpolitik und darum sind
wir auch als Union auch in der
positionszeit intensiv im Austausch mit
Familienverbänden die sehr genau
aufzeigen können was für die Familien
gerade in belasteten Situationen
vielleicht gut oder weniger gut ist über
die Umsatzsteuer hat man Kollege schon
einiges gesagt der Antrag ist fast
deckungsgleich mit dem alten Antrag die
Argumente sind ausgetauscht worden auch
angesichts des Antrags der Linken
seinerzeit dazu brauche ich nicht mehr
zu sagen aber zweitens wir sind als
Union nicht nur steuerpolitisch für
Familien unterwegs sondern eben auch im
Bereich der Familien Sozialleistungen
haben wir Vorstellungen geäußern und
weiterentwickelt wie diese
zusammengeführt werden sollen und können
es ist unser gemeinsames Ziel sollte es
jeden sein den Familien im Bedarfsfall
den Zugang zu den notwendigen Leistungen
zu erschließen und Herr Stroh die so oft
sie das das Projekt Kinder also
Grundsicherung aufrufen desto mehr meine
Zweifel ob das jemals was wird das ist
wie so ein Zauberwort wie eine
beruhigungsformel da kommt irgendwann
mal die Kindergrundsicherung dann werdet
ihr alle staunen was sie kann ich mache
mir große Sorge dass bis dahin die
Familien die Hilfe brauchen längst du in
die höher sein meine Damen und Herren
Kinder sollen kein Armutsrisiko sein und
sollen auch nicht darauf beschränkt
werden kinder sind willkommen in der
Gesellschaft und sie sind ein Gewinn
auch und nicht nur für unsere Eltern
Kinder zu erziehen hat jemand mal gesagt
braucht es ein ganzes Dorf aber nicht
eines füllhorns das unüberlegt
ausgeschüttet wird und darum müssen wir
den Antrag müssen wir beide antreiben
wie vorliegen ablegen danke für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
und für die hat damit kommen wir hier
zur letzten Rednerin bevor diese Anträge
überwiesen werden das ist Melanie
wegling für die SPD und sie sitzt im
Finanzausschuss sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die AFD meint familienentlasten
zu wollen hört hört doch was ich
dahinter verbirgt ist ein Vehikel für
ein reaktionäres Familien und Frauenbild
wenn ich mir das durchlese bekomme ich
ehrlicherweise eine Gänsehaut dann
lassen wir es mal genau hingucken wer
profitiert denn eigentlich von einer
Verschärfung des aktuellens das sind vor
allem wir haben es heute schon gehört
Familien mit höherem Einkommen und
zugleich die Familien wurde
Einkommensunterschied zwischen den
beiden verdienenden besonders groß ist
was fördert ein solches plitingen also
traditionelle Rollenbilder man
Alleinverdiener Frau zu Hause bekommt
möglichst viele Kinder
da also soll ein antiquiertes Bild einer
traditionellen Familie mit einem
männlichen Alleinverdiener steuerlich
zementiert werden dass Frauen abhängiger
und womöglich im Alter
ärmer macht doch genug zu diesem
aufgewärmten Antrag auf aus der
afd-mottenkiste hin zu dem was Familie
in all ihrer Vielfalt tatsächlich
befähigt und was unser
gesellschaftlichen Realität im 21
Jahrhundert entspricht was wir brauchen
ist eine Politik die Familien
unterstützt so dass beide arbeiten gehen
können so dass Frauen finanziell
unabhängig und beruflich ausgefüllt sind
und so dass wir dem Fachkräftemangel
entgegenwirken wir können es uns doch
gar nicht mehr leisten dass ein
Elternteil zu Hause bleibt oder nur mit
wenigen Stunden arbeitet wir brauchen
gerade auch die oftmals gut
ausgebildeten und hochqualifizierten
Frauen auf einem Arbeitsmarkt der
händeringend Fachkräfte sucht
doch noch immer ist die Erwerbsquote von
Frauen in Deutschland deutlich niedriger
als die der Männer und vor allem sind
sie viel häufiger als Männer in Teilzeit
und geringfügiger Beschäftigung tätig
mehr als die Hälfte der Frauen arbeitet
in Teilzeit in 75 Prozent aller
Haushalte sind Frauen die schlechter
verdienenden
75%. was sorgt für diese
75%. was lässt die Frauen zu Hause
bleiben das empfehlen die Kitaplätze das
sind ungeeignete Elternzeit und Minijob
Regelungen und das ist auch ganz
maßgeblich unser Steuersystem namentlich
das ehegattens plitting das Negative
Arbeitsanreize für Frauen setzt und dass
die AFD nun auch noch ausbauen möchte
zum Glück sieht die Ampel im
Koalitionsvertrag weitaus vernünftigere
familienpolitische Maßnahmen vor einige
wurden schon umgesetzt wir bekämpfen
Kinderarmut und sichern Familien besser
finanziell ab durch die Jungs
beschlossene Kindergeld Erhöhung sowie
die ersten Schritte hin zu einer
modernen Kinder Grund
wir unterstützen Eltern dabei die
erwerbs- und sorgearbeit gerechter
untereinander aufzuteilen dazu stärken
wir schulen und Kitas nicht zuletzt mit
dem kita-qualitätsgesetz über das wir am
Freitag abstimmen werden die
Partnermonate beim Elterngeld werden
erweitert Alleinerziehende
selbstständige und auch Pflegeeltern
besser berücksichtigt
und was mir persönlich ganz wichtig ist
wir wollen mit einem gerechteren
Steuersystem für eine höhere
Erwerbsbeteiligung von Frauen Sorgen das
ist nicht nur ein Gebot des
Arbeitsmarktes den weiteren verbreiteten
Fachkräftemangel habe ich erwähnt es ist
schlicht ein Gebot der wirtschaftlichen
Vernunft Frauen sind oft besser
ausgebildet und wollen oft mehr arbeiten
dieses Potenzial darf nicht ungenutzt
bleiben und es ist auch ein Gebot der
Gerechtigkeit besser ausgebildet aber
schlechter bezahlt das ist schlichtweg
ungerecht für jede einzelne Frau ist es
eine ganz konkrete Frage der
gesellschaftlichen Teilhabe der
Chancengleichheit und der
Gleichberechtigung Frauen müssen
finanziell und in ihrer Lebensführung
unabhängig sein können sie müssen
arbeiten gehen können und gerecht
bezahlt werden um auch eine gute Rente
zu bekommen
die Wirtschaftsweisen und auch dass die
Idee analysieren ganz klar eine höhere
Erwerbstätigkeit von Frauen bedeutet
mehr verfügbare Fachkräfte sorgt damit
für Wachstumsimpulse reduziert weibliche
Altersarmut und entlastet auch die
gesetzliche Rentenversicherung durch
höhere Beiträge folglich raten Ökonomen
zu einer Reform des Ehegattensplittings
die stärkere Arbeitsanreize für die eine
unterbeschäftigte Hälfte der
Ehegemeinschaft setzt die Vorstellung
der AFD würden genau das Gegenteil
bewirken wir brauchen also viele eine
Reform der Steuerklassen so dass nicht
mehr ein antiquiertes Familienmodell und
eine fatale Frauenrolle steuerlich
gefördert werden sondern eine höhere
Erwerbsbeteiligung von Frauen und damit
auch eine gerechtere Aufteilung der
erwerbs-
was wir hier im Bundestag als großen
rahmensteuer und familienpolitisch
umsetzen können das ist die eine Seite
die andere Seite zeigt für mich das
inspirierende Beispiel des female
finance Forums dass ich die finanzielle
Unabhängigkeit von Frauen auf die Fahnen
geschrieben hat seine Gründerin die
Ökonomen Claudia Müller habe ich vor
kurzem kennengelernt sie bietet
Workshops und Weiterbildung exklusiv für
Frauen zu der Fragestellung an welche
Rolle spielen Finanzen bei der
Gleichberechtigung wie sichere ich mich
finanziell für die Familienplanung und
das Alter oder im Falle von Scheidung
oder Unfall ab dieses Angebot aus der
Zivilgesellschaft deckt einen wichtigen
bedarf es steckt diesen Bedarf aber vor
allem weil unsere Finanz Familie und
Arbeitsmarktpolitik Frauen noch viel zu
stark benachteiligen als
finanzpolitikerin ist es mir ein
Anliegen das zu ändern und dabei spielt
ein gerechtere Steuersystem eine
maßgebende Rolle das aktuelle aus der
1950er Jahren stammen die
Ehegattensplitting schafft finanzielle
Abhängigkeit und damit Ungerechtigkeit
Zeit der afd-vorschlag würde diese
toxischen Effekte noch weiter verstärken
die darin erwähnten Maßnahmen sind nicht
nur familienfeindlich und reaktionär
sondern verfestigen das Armutsrisiko der
Frauen und wirken sogar wachstumshemmend
eine vernünftige Finanzpolitik für
unsere Welt von heute stärkt dagegen die
finanzielle Unabhängigkeit der Frauen
und damit unsere Familien unsere
Wirtschaft und unsere gesamte
Gesellschaft vielen Dank
viele schließe die Aussprache und in der
fraktionell wird die Überweisung der
Vorlagen auf den Drucksachen 46 72 und
46-68 an die in der Tagesordnung
aufgeführten Ausschüsse vorgeschlagen
gibt es weiter bedeutet also dass wir
noch über diese Anträge diskutieren
werden bzw die Abgeordneten erst in den
Ausschüssen und dann natürlich auch noch
einmal im Plenum